at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking this episode is brought to you
by linked-in marketing solutions the
go-to tool for b2b marketers and
advertisers who want to drive brand
awareness generate leads or build
long-term relationships that result in
real business impact could be all of the
above I've had Reid Hoffman co-founder
of LinkedIn on this podcast a number of
times often called the Oracle of Silicon
Valley for many different reasons and he
among other people and friends of mine
have made me more and more interested in
LinkedIn as a platform as an ecosystem
in the last few years and it's it's very
nuanced it's very subtle but can be used
in some very powerful ways with a
community of more than five hundred and
seventy five million professionals
LinkedIn is gigantic but it can be hyper
specific you have access to a very
diverse group of people all searching
for things they need to grow
professionally that is explicitly the
purpose of LinkedIn so you can build
relationships that really matter that
can drive your business objectives
forward that can also have a high LTV
lifetime value LinkedIn has the
marketing tools to help you target your
customers with precision right down to
among other things their job title
company name industry etc this is
important because better targeting
equals a message that your customers
actually care about and it also means
your advertising is more effective and
cost effective
so why spray-and-pray with your
marketing dollars when you can be
surgical it just makes sense to redeem a
free $100 LinkedIn ad credit and launch
your first campaign go to linkedin.com
forward slash TFS that stands for Tim
Ferriss show
so that is linkedin.com forward slash
TFS check it out that's where you can go
to get your free $100 ad credit LinkedIn
com forward slash TFS terms and
conditions apply
this episode of the tim ferriss show is
brought to you by 99designs 99designs is
the global creative platform that makes
it easy for creators and clients to work
together from logos to apps and
packaging to book covers just about
anything can be found on 99designs which
is a go to creative resource for any
budget that i've used for many many
years now 99 design now offers guess
what custom video which is very exciting
they will match you at the right video
professional to help you explain your
product spotlight a service and bring
your brand to life and like I mentioned
I've used 99 designs for all sorts of
things I've used them for book covers
some of the mock-ups for the 4-hour body
for example which went on to become a
number one New York Times best seller
illustrations beautiful illustrations
cover and inside illustrations for the
multi-volume The Tao of Seneca which you
can find online for free that is a
collection of my favorite letters that
I've read hundreds of times by Seneca
and other graphic design projects most
recently I used 99 designs to update the
illustrations and layout of my 5 morning
rituals ebook which is something that I
offer as an incentive on my website for
people to sign up for my free newsletter
the illustrations turned out fantastic
and I loved working with a designer who
we selected for the project you can
check out a bunch of these projects you
can see real-life examples of what I've
done and the stories behind them at
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim the
number 99 designs com forward slash Tim
9 and designs will match you with the
right professional for your project from
their curated community of talents and
creatives and stay with you every step
of the way so you love the outcome so
check it out head to 99designs dot-com
forward slash Tim to learn more and get
started on your project today
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to deconstruct world
class performers of all different types
whether they come from military
entertainment sports business it's a
pretty wide spectrum and today my guest
is Graham Duncan you can find him at
Graham Duncan blog East Rock Capcom and
at Graham Duncan NYC on Twitter Graham
is the co-founder of east rock capital
an investment firm that manages
approximately two billion for a small
number of families and their charitable
foundations before starting east rock 14
or so years ago Graham worked at two
other investment firms he started his
career by co-founding an independent
Wall Street research firm Graham
graduated from Yale with a BA in ethics
politics and economics it's a lot of
stuff he is a member of the Council on
Foreign Relations and serves as co-chair
of the Sohn Conference Foundation which
funds pediatric cancer research Josh
Waitzkin one of our very good mutual
friends will probably pop up here and
there in this conversation thought of
most often as the basis for searching
for bobby fisher' although he would
cringe to hear we limited to hat calls
Graham quote the tip of the spear in the
realms of talent tracking and judgment
of human potential and high-stakes
mental arenas end quote that is a very
Josh sentence and the Graham it is a
real pleasure to be sitting here with
you thanks Ben thanks particular time
and we we've had many conversations we
haven't caught up in a while we've also
had terrible food poisoning together
along with Josh so I feel like we've
we've seen each other in high stakes
maybe not mental physical arenas we if I
recall correctly almost decapitated each
other when learning to paddleboard with
Josh at one point and I am excited to
chat for a lot of reasons number one I
always learn something when we sit down
and talk and I don't think of you first
and foremost
as an investor you you certainly do that
very well but I enjoy watching your
thinking and listening to your thinking
so I think that for people who are in
the audience and who might be wondering
right off the bat how will this apply to
me it is hopefully transferable to just
about any domain I think that thinking
clear thinking is really a lot of what
we'll be discussing but for people who
just heard this bio and are kind of
scratching their heads as to what you
exactly do how do you how do you explain
what you do
well I try to find people who are better
at doing a thing than I am at doing that
thing and I first came to this 20 years
ago I just started a firm with a
professor of mine at Yale and we were
running this independent research firm
and I had hired a sales guy who we're
two years in and we were in a group
meeting and he says to me at a certain
point grim what the [ __ ] do you do here
and at that point I had some real
imposter syndrome going because I was
hiring and firing 30 people have much
older much more experience than me
and so I've sat there for 30 seconds
because it's a good question what the
[ __ ] do I do
and I finally said to him you know
Robert when you first interviewed to
come to our firm you were applying to be
an analyst and I was interviewing you as
an analyst I didn't see your eyes light
up when we talked about political
analysis or economic analysis but then
you proceeded to stalk me for the
following four weeks you called me at
home back then you emailed me twice a
day and I had this moment of Revelation
I was also interviewing salespeople
Robert should be our salesperson and you
trusted me enough to come and try it and
now you've built our entire business and
I'm not a good analyst I'm not a good
salesperson but I put you in that seat
and now we've built this thing I put you
into this positive feedback loop that we
are calling a business here
and that's what I do and I feel like
it's a I wouldn't pick that skill out of
a lineup as my thing it's the cards I
was dealt its what I end up being
compulsive about and interested in in
this way the world seems to like me
doing it but it's kind of an odd
it's an odd center of gravity but today
I think about it as my mission in life
is to get as many people as possible
into positive feedback loops and there's
a it's it's a good skill to have because
it's right next to a weakness of mine
which is I'm kind of lazy maybe that's
why we get along as in there so I like
getting the design right up front so
that I don't have to it had to be
talking to Robert once a week as a
political analyst saying look you're not
do this don't do that that would have
been it I don't I don't want to put
something into somebody I want to have
them do the thing that they want to do
anyway and if you if you construct
organizations and teams that way that
you unlock a lot of stuff so for me
today I use that philosophy a lot
because I act in effect as a general
contractor for families to manage their
wealth in order to do that my team and I
meet over a thousand teams a year to try
to hire the best investment craftsmen of
any given sub strategy and sometimes
those craftsmen those investment
managers who were trapped inside large
organizations start their own firms on
their own or where their help and you
you unleash all this extra investment
energy and genius said they weren't
accessing in their prior context and we
get to participate in that together with
them so it's now been 20 years but I
feel like I've basically been playing
different variations of the same game
and at that time how old were you
roughly 24 call it 24 so we're gonna
we're gonna talk I'm sure a lot about
this and well I won't make this just a a
list of Josh quotes but I mean I was
texting with him and he reiterated I
think we just said and Josh my apologies
I know we didn't talk about me reading
your text upfront but this is pretty
safe so a core genius
Graham is talent hunting finding funky
eight-plus that funky word on at some
point we're gonna talking about eight
plus potential mental performers in the
finance space and then he then he goes
on now you have systems and frameworks
that you use for this at twenty four
though I I would be really curious to
hear you try to describe what made you
good at it and then also if there's
anything that comes to mind is there any
any if there are there things that you
see that other people tend not to see or
are there any types of questions that
you ask yourself that even at that point
perhaps you had picked up along the way
this is is there is there anything that
comes to mind well I think of it as
having a certain taste in people and I
like taste because and I think I had a
certain taste back then and it's evolved
and I can articulate a little better
than I could back then but I mean if you
think of taste I like taste or judgment
because judgment implies there's one
answer whereas taste is you have a
certain taste in podcast guest right
there's something similar to the group
and you could pick a Tim guest out of a
lineup in a way right tall dark and
handsome yeah so taste like I so I'm
trying to think back then I think the
imposter thing kind of helped because I
I knew I was trying to hire people who
are better at doing a thing than I was
at doing it and I knew I couldn't do it
and so I was forced to say okay what
constitutes excellence in this thing and
I hi we had hired a bunch of in that
context we'd hired a bunch of sales guys
and they they actually didn't like cold
calling and a lot of sales guys
understandably don't like the rejection
of cold calling and I found this one guy
but for whatever reason thrives on it
like a couple years ago I ran into
somebody who was a client or prospective
client of ours back then and he said I
still dream there this guy Robert is
trying to get me on the phone
and I wake up in cold sweats in the
middle the night we built our entire
business on this guy and that's so
there's there's like this yeah so I
think it's seeing and I'm just I find
myself curious about what makes people
tick in this way that I don't get tired
of it and how is that tastes evolved
today so if a component of that tastes
or at least alerting your spider-sense
is identifying certain outliers saying
preferences or behaviors back then like
Robert thriving on cold call rejection
what are your tastes look like today or
more recently or what constitutes your
taste when you're scouting for talent or
evaluating talent in in the world which
you now operate well I I like framing
I've read once that people are like
musical instruments and the range of
notes they can play is dependent on the
range of tensions that they've learned
to hold and I like that because it it
acknowledges that everybody whatever
they're playing right now there's
actually other notes they can play in a
different context so as an example the
tension I'm focused on right now in the
investment management world is I think
there's something really interesting
about the tension between someone's
intensity and integrity or if you
double-click on each of those aggression
and humility and if you if you were to
rank I to try to use a concrete example
I've written an essay before about David
Tepper I don't know David Tepper he's
somewhat in the public domain he's on
CNBC he's written some and I think of
David Tepper in many ways as the
Platonic ideal of a good hedge fund
manager and a good investor and one
thing is holds is like I think people
work for him but I've interviewed people
have worked for him they experience them
as as that mix of like super aggressive
in taking a position
in an equity or debt security from zero
to 20 percent of the fund with no no
hesitation like if you were and yet if
you were on the other side of a
transaction with him he's not going to
do something that you characterize a I
mean you would never say fraudulent but
he's not going to be overly aggressive
like he's playing the game because he
enjoys it but he has an ethical core I
feel like that tension at Goldman Sachs
sailor's term is someone commercial and
I think of that I love that word word
and I think of commercial as people give
off this vibe of I'm going to create
more value than I capture here versus
somebody's more transactional is trying
to capture all the value and people who
are commercial who balance that tension
of aggression and integrity or
aggression and humility they tend to
clump two together they like doing
business with each other and so you hit
these pockets of people with that how do
you test for something like that and or
stress tested in the sense that I would
imagine many of the people if not all of
the people who make it to the point that
they're interacting with you or your
team I have have already cleared a lot
of hurdles they've already checked a lot
of boxes and many of them will be good
at selling themselves and no one is
going to volunteer that they lack
integrity so if you go well there is
this one thing I'm very very very
skilled and intelligent you know
deceptive artists never so how do you
try to evaluate that well one evolution
of my process has been I just treat my
interview as one perspective and then
people think of references is this thing
you do after the fact to me it's the
whole thing references and getting the
sense of so how someone's interacting in
a repeat iteration gain in this thing we
call financial markets to me that's the
people generate trust and it's like this
intangible asset that's around them and
the trust sits in the heads of everybody
they've interacted with over time and my
job is to see how everybody else they've
interacted with their employees their
former bosses their peers end up
relating to them in the way because of
the body of work they've had in the past
and so like we did that dinner with
Chris Fussell that time I think Russell
and Stan McChrystal is language around
trying to assess someone's credibility
and then based on that assessment
how much decision space to give them to
me that's so beautiful and that's
exactly how I think about what I do so
and they have this formula credibility
equals proven competence plus
relationships plus integrity and so what
I'm trying to do when I'm trying to
understand for instance someone's
integrity is understand how they behaved
in Prior moments of stress right so 2008
wasn't amazing for anybody that's still
investing who was around in 2008 it's a
great moment to check in on how they
behave during that period because that
was like an earthquake going off and it
tested every single possible human
relationship tested when people were
partners in investing and they're both
portfolio managers a lot of people got
divorced after that limited partners the
people invest in hedge funds and the
general partners that tested those
relationships tested people's
relationships with the bank's so if
they've been around a while to me an
interesting question is what happened in
o8 like and I'm sure we'll have
additional crises soon that will and
again
enable us to separate those who behave
well from those who behave badly in
those periods of stress so it's super
reference focused and then I have a
series of questions I ask people that I
feel like have high signal value but but
again I to have a lot of humility and a
light grip on my ability in what you
know in a one-hour meeting to to figure
now you know what are some of the the
high signal questions that or the that
you've that you've filtered through over
time and have found to be particularly
useful do any come to mind or are types
of questions well the the matter one
that I think applies whether you're
looking for you know an OBGYN for your
wife to have a kid or anything is you
ask somebody if you were hiring somebody
to do this what criteria would you use
to hire that's a great question because
what's what it captures is their
definition of success and also captures
some nuance that you wouldn't even known
to ask about so when my wife and I were
looking for an OB do and this was my
question and one guy said well what what
you're maximizing for is the downside
and if you have some sort of you know if
the baby is in distress you need a good
NICU so my primary criteria Nicki's
needle intensive care unit so and the
the best NIC use are usually attached to
teaching hospitals like Mount Sinai so I
would look for affiliation of that
doctor with a good NICU and then I would
also act he is a great criteria was I
would ask the nurses because the nurses
know who freaks out during tricky
situations and who's got ice in their
veins and who makes good decisions who
treats people well in those settings and
the nurses let the good nurses want to
work for the best doctors in that
hospital setting and I actually have
this thought that the equivalent in
financial markets is are the traders the
traders are in the receiving end of a
portfolio managers decisions and they
often have a very strong sense of who
the good investors are like David
Peppers trader I bet my and again I
don't know this but my hypothesis would
be there an off David Tepper because
they're on the receiving end of when
he's buying when everybody else is
freaking out now you have to be careful
and one of the arts of references I
think is controlling for the context
the perspective of the reference giver
traitors like traitors right so if
somebody doesn't trade a lot they they
may not think as highly of this
portfolio manager who's really more of a
buy-and-hold person and it doesn't give
them any business and they think it's
kind of lazy well okay that could be
true but it also could be just they run
a super concentrated portfolio they only
buy one thing here so but so I really
like what criteria would you use and and
the other great thing about the question
is it includes your own criteria for the
next interview right yeah that is that's
that's that's really really fascinating
I was just chatting with a friend of
mine
Toby who's the CEO of Shopify and the
way he learned the business side is he
went to Silicon Valley and met with
let's just call it a dozen venture
capitalists as an engineer and each
meeting he would pick up new questions
new terminology he'd be able to answer
one more question and it just improved
his ability to vets not only venture
capitalists but also to learn the lingo
and the terminology question related to
the references themselves so most folks
out there if they think of references
whether they have provided references or
binner references or they're trying to
hire is you ask the person you are
interviewing or will be interviewing for
their references
they give references who they expect to
give for Hayes and then you get in
contact with those people so there
there's a piece of which questions to
ask and then there's the piece there
many others of which people to talk to
how do you what does your process look
like for determining who to talk to as
references I actually think the
candidate giving you references is
usually obviously you want to find off
list references if you can and one
advantage of interviewing a ton of
people in a given thing is often you
know
people that they've worked with in other
contexts that they didn't give but I
actually find on list references like
bizarrely high signal value because what
happens is after 10 minutes on a
reference people run out of like nobody
wants to lie they run out of their
script they run out of their script and
so one of my closest friendships in the
business was when somebody runs another
family office was calling me on a
reference on somebody and my job I went
into that call taking okay I like this
guy we don't have money with him I
respect him he stuck man his reference
list okay
and the guy sat on me for an hour and
would not allow me to basically give you
know a positive endorsement without
specifics and so I think of it as a Net
Promoter Score so at the you know either
at the beginning or the end of a
reference I'll say okay what I hear you
saying is you're kind of giving this guy
a seven on the Net Promoter Score is
that right did I hear that quickly or
I'll just ask it regular on a 1 to 10
what's your level of endorsement of this
person if I was calling you on a
reference on let's make up a fictional
assistant that worked for you four years
ago and I was debating hiring them well
first we know each other so I would I
would do it in person I track you down
and say Tim so what's the skinny but
let's say we don't know each other that
well and I'm calling on a phone I would
be trying to understand okay are you
still in touch with that assistant what
you're like what's the social dynamic I
make it safe for you look I'm calling 20
people I am NOT passing any of that
information back to the candidate unless
you asked me to so you need to make it
safe for them but yeah so but if at the
end I've got in effect an aggregate
number of Net Promoter scores on a
different person machines after
reference number four and and then you
know you can stop because you're hearing
the same thing over and over again you
know one and this I mean I'm very
primitive of course you've done
infinitely more hiring but I remember
this bit of advice that I was given by
think about who it was I'm blanking on
who exactly it was
Kyle Maynard is who it was quadruple
congenital amputees climb Kilimanjaro
and was a star wrestler fascinating guy
he learned and I think from might've
been it was from it was from very
successful CEO and was the rank X could
be anything from one to ten but you
can't use a seven right and I have used
that in restaurants I have used that for
so many things and it removes that safe
mild endorsement when you are when you
are then speaking to these references
who have been provided are there any
other any other approaches you use to
ferret out weaknesses well one meta one
stance that I think is really important
is that I'm not trying to catch somebody
in in any way I'm just curious and I'm
trying and the references pick up on
this vibe and I want to help the
candidate construct the best environment
for them right right because that's
there's no gotcha to it like we're all
crazy we all have lots of weaknesses you
know and so one thing I see other people
in there : trolls to me do is they have
this one thing that I see other people
who are an equivalent roles to me right
who is they have this gotcha writing
which I don't agree with like so all I'm
trying to do is help the person get in
the best possible context for them and
so so that's I feel like that stance
elicits a lot more because then you're
on the same side
mm-hm particularly you're talking to a
former boss or you know so that's I
guess that's how I think about it yeah
yeah it's or the the mindset with which
you go into it and they tone that you
transmit yeah one question I like to ask
is if I were gonna hire a partner for
this person to compliment their
strengths or weaknesses what would that
person be good at right because then
it's like any other be careful
context you want it to be another
investing partner because and then I
actually used that and then I can help
it to the extent it's applicable help
that person try to make sure because
their one misconception I feel like
people have sometimes is that there are
our products in my opinion in investment
management there are no products they're
the only humans and that's why I'm so
focused on the people side of it and the
only product is the mindset of the
individual and the decisions they were
going to make prospectively from here
right so if you were invested in a fund
at fidelity and the portfolio manager
leaves and there's a new portfolio
manager from my perspective that's that
that's a completely new decision right
the only right whereas some people have
a mentality of oh I'm looking to put out
a starts with a I think a dangerous that
mindset which is I'm going to put out
some assets and to do that I'm going to
invest in some products I think you
don't want to have the mindset of I've
need to put out assets like you always
want to feel comfortable holding cash
and there should be no pressure but
money to work and then secondarily it's
to the extent you're going and at in my
role we're pretty indifferent on do we
have people in house or out you know out
in the field most of the time external
teams are the most commercial people
want to run in their own firms and so we
have a biased we over time have
constructed what I think of as a team of
teams but it's not you know it's not a
product of products there is no no no
that that makes a lot of sense to me and
this may or may not be I just I want to
bring up a term that Josh suggested
bringing up and this may not be the
right place but that's okay because this
podcast is always all over the place
like momento wild he said ask ask Graham
about wild gardening no I'm gonna laugh
if this is actual literally wild
gardening and it's just a complete non
sequitur but he put it in quotation
marks so he
so he calls me the wild gardener because
I don't like to force it
I don't want so there's a there's a
great piece in Atlantic Monthly from
years ago where someone looking at the
temperament of children divided them
into orchids and dandelions and it's a
little bit similar to the Susan Cain
high-sensitivity there's another thinker
named Elaine Aaron who has this concept
of a highly sensitive children HSCs and
the idea is that if you get orchids can
be so beautiful but they need just the
right context they need the right light
temperature and dandelions are just
lower maintenance but maybe have less
potential that's not the right language
but they the dandelions you don't have
to worry about the context as much and
so I think of partly what I do is back
to the the the system design is okay
let's get everybody into a positive
feedback loop doing what they're
actually compulsive about what they
actually can have a chance of being
world-class at and I don't like trying
to stick a dandelion where it doesn't
want to be or North could where it
doesn't want to be and I it's let's so
we're talking about we're covering a lot
that relates to talent selection and
asking the right questions we're
definitely going to spend some time on
questions that you ask yourself as well
since that's it in part large part what
thinking is a day-to-day but I want to
talk a bit about ambiguity or cases that
are not exceptionally clear so you if
you talk to say 20 references and all 20
come back and say this person is
fantastic
let me list the ways then that's one
thing or if they're all negative but
no doubt you've had instances where you
get negative feedback or perhaps you
have a lot of positive within one on a
scale of one to ten and severity is like
a nine or ten severity negative how do
you how do you handle cases like that
how do you think through something that
is not at least at first glance
extremely obvious it's a lot of life is
like this yeah yeah or if there any
cases any examples not naming names but
yeah I think it's a matter of holding
those contradictory perspectives as long
as you need to to make sense of them and
so for me people my wife my business
parking experience me as indecisive at
times because I'm so tolerant of holding
the ambiguity on somebody being really
good at something because everyone's
genius is right next to their
dysfunction I think and so you until
you're clear on it it can feel and
sometime you you just don't get clear in
which case there's no need to do
anything but one central strategy I have
of dealing is just spending more time
with them you know we got to know each
other well on these intense surfing
trips where we almost drowned unless the
headed you and we got food poisoning but
and I like in general welcome to Club
Paradise yeah I like getting out of the
conference room and not being pitched
something across the table and I like
creating other context to interact with
people and if there's ambiguity or
impotence we'll look at investment with
them a lot if you look at something
that's live with somebody you learn so
much about how they're actually
underwriting it the mental models
they're using what do you mean by
underwriting in this case so
underwriting is a term used in the
context of making an investment decision
and or refers to the body of work that
an individual or say a deal team has
done to get comfortable advocating for
an investment at a particular price and
so like people will say based on my
underwriting
are attractive relative to the risk in
this case and bye-bye saying my
underwriting they are putting their
their personal reputation behind the
projections and they're taking ownership
of the outcome of that analysis so if we
were looking at a real estate investment
in Washington DC in a potential hotel
we would rather than investing in a fund
we would if we were getting a note a new
partner spent a lot of time on that
literally looking at that hotel
investment and understanding the how the
sponsor is looking at at the investment
and in that way you get to know oh this
is what they're really focused on this
is what their strengths are and maybe we
should keep an eye out for these
weaknesses or if we make the investment
in a fund of theirs this is something we
keep an eye on and just for just for
people who may not have put the pieces
together and I want you to correct me
here but you're you're in effect you
have as as clients your limited partners
family offices so these are wealthy
families who want your help in then
choosing different investment teams and
you are in a way as was that the team
coach who is selecting the players yeah
so we work with a handful of families
who get to know us well and trust us to
be their outsourced chief investment
officer they basically give us full
investment discretion over their wealth
outside of their personal property and
we manage that as one pool for them and
diversified across asset classes so we
miss that pool and say a commercial real
estate project in Seattle that would
make with our real estate partners that
are local there or in hedge fund
partnerships run by the best teams we
can find all over the world so if
somebody's got a fund we'll look at
their fund if they have an S BV a
special purpose vehicle where they're
investing in a publicly traded security
or a private investment we'll look at
that they want to start a fund will help
them start a fund if they don't need our
capital in a seat context but they just
are looking for arm's length normal
limit
partners will do that so we try to be as
opportunistic and open-minded as
possible about it and yeah are there any
other patterns that you've spotted in
the talent you end up selecting that
does well and the reason I ask is that
from from what I've observed and this is
not my world but just hanging out on the
sidelines every once in a while glancing
over at my perception of what you do is
that you're you're picking folks meaning
investors who are they're not Tepper
necessarily right I mean they are kind
of rookie MVPs or maybe that's not the
right description but you may not have a
ton of data on these folks it feel free
to fact be in effect correct any of that
so are there any any other
characteristics that seem to pop up more
often than not in these in the people
who end up doing well that you select
yeah I'd say in addition to that
aggression humility tension a second one
I think about is originality and triage
or these two so we've noticed that the
people who do best tend to have lots of
ideas there's a academic named Dean
Simonton who studied genius across field
and he observed that whether it was Bach
or any given scientists the the sheer
number of compositions that Bach had
were like a hundred times more than
average composers and some of his lousy
his lousy pieces of music were inferior
to his peers at the time but then he
also ended up with some great pieces so
there's something around just sheer
quantity of ideas and original thinking
that characterizes a lot of them
specifically you'll notice that in the
language that people use so I feel like
as you in any field I think when you
start to achieve mastery you start often
people start creating their own language
to capture the nuance that they're
seeing that makes them good at their
thing an investment management Buffett
is kind
the Shakespeare of the industry and
everybody is living in his language and
in his mental models to the point where
it's limiting so I feel like a 25 year
old sometimes will be saying I'm sitting
on cash just waiting for the fat pitch
and I can't tell whether he knows he's
quoting Buffett or not and even if he's
doing it consciously he's living in this
construct which is a super useful
construct but the if he proceeds to
become the temper of his generation he
will he'll generate his own language
over the course of a subsequent 20 years
and so when people use a lot of jargon
and cliches and language that at times
doesn't feel like their own to me that's
a sign that maybe they're a little bit
earlier and they could use another stage
of apprenticeship or you know they just
that we would probably wait till to a
later stage and then that second
component when people have lots of ideas
they're usually not that good at killing
them
so it's a tension with this triage
mentality of look I'm here to make money
I'm gonna force rank somebody's gonna
die here and I'm gonna choose these I'm
gonna save these four people and let
this guy die right is that triage high
situational awareness okay I'm making
live trade-offs here I think that's a
quality that really good portfolio
managers have where they can force rank
their portfolio and they can kill their
own ideas and so I you see that often
and then just back to aggressiveness I
was interviewing a guy and he was
talking about what he's looking for one
question I like to ask people is if you
were hiring an analyst what criteria are
you looking for at the analyst and
people who have been managing money and
managing people before begin to look for
things in their analysts that make those
analysts most valuable to them right and
so there's there's often signal in the
way they answer that I said you know I'm
looking for is a trace of fear in myself
that this guy is coming for me he will
replace me and I think what he's
capturing is that agree that that level
of intensity that obsessiveness that you
see in a minority probably in any field
because of just they've they found their
game the game they want to play in there
they bring in intensity and
obsessiveness to it that overtime
they're just working so much harder and
they're so that you know it's like
waiting Gretzky finding you know hockey
at age five right like he's just he's
obsessed it he's just going over and
over and over again and there are people
in that planets industry or like that is
just obsessed with investing in this
really distinctive way Warren Buffett is
it from a young age obsessed John Arnold
obsessed you mentioned you mentioned
something I want to come back to for a
second which I may omit I don't think
I'll misrepresent I think I'll probably
get it but the mentioned Buffett and the
terminology and the language phrasing
that he popularized as well originates
that popularizes and how people compare
it that with and leading you to wonder
whether they really understand what
they're speaking about or simply
repeating something from someone who's
well regarded right and this makes me
think of richard fineman and how his dad
used to tell him that there's a big
difference and a paraphrasing here but
between knowing the label write the word
or the phrase and understanding what
that label is intended to represent and
you can learn so much about not only
others but yourself and your own
thinking by looking at the language that
you use and one of the questions I
wanted to ask you because it came up
when you were in tribal mentors was how
you improve your own thinking and
something that stuck out to me and I'm
gonna gonna track it down here this was
in response to wait what is one of the
best or the most worthwhile investments
you've ever made and I'll just I'll skip
around here but the first line was I
invested disproportionate amount of my
income in paying for an ever-growing
collection of trainers and coaches and
you mentioned handful and one of them
you said is the most gifted listener
I've ever encountered she surfaces my
hidden assumptions the ones that hold me
rather than me holding them and teaches
me to ask better and better question
how does whether it's this person
specifically or others help you to
surface your hidden assumptions this
strikes me as so so key to just about
everything and investing just happens to
sort of magnify the consequences very
often obviously of of assumptions and
faulty assumptions but how would a coach
help you to surface your hidden
assumptions or how might they well this
woman Caroline Coughlin in particular is
within this Bob Keegan School of he's a
professor at Harvard and he has a theory
about adult development which is that
the process of moving through adulthood
is one of increasing your mental
complexity and increasing the number of
things that used to be you used to be
subject to assumptions you had you
couldn't see and making them object over
time so an example for many people would
be if they grew up in a religious
context are they actively choosing their
religious beliefs or did they arrive at
them because their parents and community
you know there everyone was swimming in
those beliefs together and so well I
feel like a really good coach can do is
by listening of the way you're making
the listening the way I'm making sense
of something can observe
oh you're actually assuming X your grip
I think of it as a grip like your grip
on certain things is really tight and if
if a coach can find what you're gripping
really tightly and you're actually not
you can't articulate the opposite of
this belief you have that might be a
sign that you have identity or ego
caught up in that thing can you think of
an example so one assumption my business
partner pointed out to me recently that
I seem to have
be holding a little bit strongly is what
he was calling futurism that I'm ready
for things to be disrupted in and
paranoid about disruption in this way
that he observed is I'm holding I got a
little bit too tight of a grip around
things so when we're investing in a
hotel where there might be risks around
climate change I'm extra focused on the
climate change or if we're investing in
somebody a value investor who's often
going long things that Silicon Valley's
trying to disrupt my partner's
observation is I will be extra focused
on risks around that I think he's
totally right once he said that it kind
of clicked and I realized okay now that
doesn't mean I drop it it just means
when it comes up it's more object to me
that so yeah and in a case like that
would you practice articulating the
opposite as you mentioned earlier and
I'm just as my mind is digesting this
right now I'm thinking of I don't I mean
you have read you've heard so many books
it's just boggles the mind and so you
may be familiar with a would it wouldn't
surprise me if you're familiar with
buyer and Katie but the she has
something called the work which I think
is you have to be careful with using it
as your only hammer because then you
just start looking for nails everywhere
but you part of that practice is taking
this belief that is causing you and I'm
noting this is this is an example here
but causing you some amount of
discomfort or stress or anxiety and then
going through the exercise of stating
the exact opposite right so my dad
should be this is not a real example
making up like my dad should be more
attentive to my mom and then you stated
in a number of different ways like my
dad should be less attentive to my mom
my mom should be more attentive to my
dad etc and you you have to as part of
the exercise look for data points or
even the smallest shred of evidence that
you could put down if you were trying to
make those arguments and it helps to
disentangle emotion and attachment from
your initial kind of statement when your
partner brings to light something that
you might be gripping tightly like this
what are the next steps after that or is
just the pointing out enough it's kind
of like looking at an optical illusion
and you're like oh you see how if you
look at it this way it's actually an old
woman's face instead of an hourglass and
you can never again look at that and not
see the old woman's face yeah the Byron
Katie I've been to multiple workshops of
her I think she's amazing I knew it I
knew it I so across the street here
there's a salad place sweet greens and I
was in there maybe three months ago
listening to Byron Katie's new book a
mind at home it with itself and Byron
Katie and her husband Steven Mitchell
walk into the restaurant let's order
salads and then proceeded to sit right
next to me
unbelievable I thought I took a picture
of it because I thought I might be
tripping and then you looked at on your
computer or later and no one was there
and I will tell you they proceeded to
have the most mindful meal I think I may
have ever witnessed there are some gurus
who out of context you think you know
are not walking their talk in this
particular case I have I can affirm that
she is like her stage presence to extent
you've seen her on stage yeah all the
time yeah and so I find her credibility
on that extra high yeah I think her
thing of you know what's the belief is
it true what's the opposite of that can
you absolutely know it's true how do you
feel when you think that thing yeah I
think it's what would you be without
this movie I think it's so powerful and
also started in trouble yeah one thing
that really caught makes I spend a
little bit of time with her a number of
months ago and I I can sort of confirm
what you just said like she she is
exactly what you would sort of expect
and hope her to be based on books did
yeah I mean the metaphysics can get
pretty mind-bending if you go in that
direction but the framing of using the
word we're talking about labels belief
like what would you be without this
belief as opposed to thought is also
really key yeah right it's like
something you take it's a statement you
take to be true right now and it's just
framing it that way puts it under a
different lens but so to your question I
think I may have a little bit of ego
identity around being unconventional or
being into technology disruption and not
thinking that the status quo is going to
continue mm-hmm and so what my business
partner is pointing out is just watch
that and now that we have it on the
table when we're evaluating an
investment it's oh you know I don't want
to be self-conscious about bringing up
the paranoia because I think it's a it's
a useful lens to have but being aware
that I'm just a tiny bit subject to that
is really useful you know and and if
you're looking at a team whether that's
within these offices you know we're
sitting in your offices right now or it
could be anything really but
specifically I guess just to keep us on
keep us in your power zone uh-uh
investing when when do you choose to
teach each individual person to offset
biases like this versus hiring another
person to provide a counterpoint and the
reason I ask is and I'm getting way
above my paygrade here but if you look
at say Buffett and Munger you know right
and Buffett's searching for bargains and
wants to sort of buy at a discount and
then Munger is I'm gonna get slaughtered
on the internet I'm sure but is sort of
teaching him over time that there are
cases where you can buy at the market
value or a fair price if the growth
trajectory is really high
and they seem to complement each other
very very well how do you think about I
so each person developing the
counterpoint or the ability to look at
the opposite versus hiring to end up at
that optimal mixture yeah
well it's back to grip so if I'm
evaluating a team I'm trying to figure
out so sometimes I'll I'll hook up
someone who has long Tesla with someone
who is short Tesla and when you're when
you're witnessing that exchange you can
see whether the person is long Tesla and
the person short Tesla are they actively
seeking you know disconfirming evidence
or is it an ideological thing and Tesla
is a little bit of an extreme example
because it's very ideological on both
sides it's not really a great example
for that reason but it's you can see it
because it's more extreme that right now
on Twitter the shorts are and musk and
the people who are long are going back
and forth the vast majority of them are
not actually looking to hold the other
person's perspective in a team context
you can you can witness whether there's
somebody who's already there
in the hedge fund industry in the
private equity industry what's cool is
that the boundary of the firm is pretty
fluid so sometimes a portfolio manager
of one firm will have a close
relationship with one to five other
portfolio managers and you define here
just for folks purpose OPM right before
Lee managers who is that person that's
the person who's running the investment
firm and who's making the investment
decisions and sizing the investments in
that portfolio the main it's the main
role and inside I mean inside a large
firm you might have multiple PM's
depending on I'm using it in your that's
a good catch I meant more cio but but if
you have investment office chief a chief
investment officer exactly but but but a
portfolio manager within a large shop
like Citadel will have external
relationships sometimes and sometimes
those by side relationships will be
testing each other's thinking and and
the equivalent of that Buffett Munger
thing often exists across firm is my so
they don't have to be within the
boundary
firm so the the looking for
disconfirming evidence I want to stick
with for a second now so this is this is
something you see certainly in any good
scientist and it's they're not setting
out to prove X they are coming up with a
hypothesis and then hopefully in is
unbiased and objective away possible
uh-huh arguably not possibly fully fully
objective trying to then assess and
actively look for disconfirming evidence
if it exists or if they can isolate it
how do you how do you train how how
could one train themselves to get better
at doing that are there and in it could
be as seemingly indirect as you like I'm
just I'm just wondering I mean it would
seem like one step would be developing
what we talked about earlier this
ability to take whatever assumption or
bias you have and then view it as an
object so they're aware of it the
meditation can help with that doing
something like Byron Katie can help with
that
are there other other things whether
there are precursors to looking for
disconfirming evidence or that habit
itself that can be that help to
cultivate well I think an underlying
paranoia that you're missing something
is really useful and the best portfolio
managers have that there they're just
that that sense that and maybe you dial
it up by remembering by regularly
reviewing all the mistakes you made and
thinking okay some percentage of the
time I see things clearly and some
percentage of the time I miss it you
know one thing about financial markets
in the publicly traded side is your hit
rate is you know a really good portfolio
managers hit rate is like 65 percent
like that's off the charts and 55
percent will do just fine in a lot of
cases depending particularly on their
slugging percentage what percentage of
how do they size the winners versus the
losers you want to size
winner is obviously bigger than the
losers so there's something around how
do you maintain paranoia and humility I
think one tricky thing in the hedge fund
space is being on the record in any way
in the form of writing letters or being
in on CNBC or being in the public domain
probably on the margin makes it harder
to drop it like a hot potato and go
short and to me the most skill portfolio
managers have an identity not as I am
smart and therefore I make money or I am
good at financial stocks but the meta
identity is I'm a money maker and if
that involves right now if in this era
in this moment in history that's going
long Tesla I'll go along Tesla will go
short Tesla I'll go short Tesla but
there's no baggage and then we're
walking into a guy who we have a ton of
money with who I really really respected
he was short Solar City and it was on
the morning that the mosque announced he
was that Tesla was buying solar say so
there's a very painful morning for
people who were short the stock and I
expected this guy to be moping around
and super pissed at Musk and he was
laughing he was enjoying it the audacity
that my that he feels like he's in this
game and oh my I didn't even I I knew it
was a possibility I didn't think he was
gonna have the hood spot to do that
right like that mentality that humor
that lightness that oh got this one
wrong on to the next one if that
particular portfolio manager ever wrote
about something in a letter he doesn't
happen to but if he did I would have no
qualms that the following month he can
easily be short the position he just and
so one nice thing about financial
markets is that long short thing the
ability to to make money by it going up
and make money by it going down and
change your position this reminds me of
something Josh decided some time ago
which was that he wouldn't at least
maybe this has changed but I doubt it
has changed
his his current circumstances which we
will get into but very unlikely he's
giving many keynotes right now
he stopped giving keynotes because he
felt like it would entrench his thinking
and calcify his positions because he
would be repeating these statements and
it's concepts that he then be less
likely to subconsciously or consciously
to modify ya know what this this is
something I ask everyone and maybe
you've heard this before but there any
particular books that you have gifted
the most to other people they don't they
don't have to relate to what we've been
discussing at all but are the you are so
widely read do any stand out as books
that you've gifted or recommended often
to other people yes
so in financial markets I really like
this somewhat obscure book called the
aspirational investor by this guy Ashvin
Chhabra who runs Jim Simon's family
office Jim Simon started Renaissance
Technologies which is the dominant
Quentin fund amazing story we're not
gonna get into it just yeah Renaissance
is really fascinating please continue
here and one thing I like about
Renaissance and Jim Simons he has this
line and a New Yorker profile of him
that he thinks what he has is really
good taste in interesting problems it
uses the word taste and it's a similar
like anyway and this guy runs his family
office used to run the endowment at the
Institute for Advanced Studies and in
the book he identifies what he sees as
the flaws in Modern Portfolio theory
which have totally dominated prevailing
beliefs about investing for decades and
Ashford suggests a totally different
approach to portfolio construction based
on how people actually behave and what
they actually care about and so that's
that's a book I get out a lot there's on
the culture side if somebody's starting
a firm I'm looking over your shoulder
because I've got a bunch of them on the
bookshelf here a tribal leadership by
Dave Logan Dave Logan goes through as
looked at thousands of organizations and
puts them into categories and Phil
Jackson the former coach of the Chicago
Bulls has observed that that framework
in trout in that Logan discusses in
tribal leadership is the best framework
for understanding world-class teams that
he's come across we can go into it if
it's of interest culture code by Daniel
Coyle I give people what do you find a
value in that book this book has come up
a lot on the podcast I still have not
read it it's come up in many different
contexts what is that book about which
struck over the last one code it's he's
looking at a bunch of different cultures
Pixar Navy SEALs we've got three others
or something he's looking for patterns
among what make people
disproportionately effective as a
culture and I think he captures some of
the nuance that if you're trying to set
up teams you it exposes you to that he'd
be a good guest on the podcast yeah
another book on my homework list check I
also like the tools I give that out
sometimes that's by Phil Stutz and Barry
Michaels have you ever heard of them I
have are they screenwriters work in
entertainment
yeah they're they're psychologists and
they're in Hollywood and they treat a
lot of screen right I see and this New
Yorker reporter Dana Dana Goodyear did a
profile of them that highlighted them
and then they wrote a book called the
tools it and they have a bunch of good
hacks in there some of the most I will
mention them by name but a few of the
few of the documentary filmmakers who
are on a very short list of documentary
filmmakers who create massively
commercially successful documentaries
have have recommended this book to me
yes that's how it first came out this is
an example it's very apropos of wim HOF
they they have this whole analogy of
saying the this model of to get to what
you want you have to go through some
pain just this pause could
describe for people who went off as if
they haven't he oh boy so yeah when off
first I think first podcast interviews
on this podcast interesting guy but
who's who's went off when maja has
developed a way of exposing himself to
the cold and and methodology around
exposing himself to the cold that he now
teaches to millions of people thanks to
you and Laird Hamilton and others
highlighting him the Iceman yeah say
yeah a dubious honor in some in some
cases because you do need to watch your
fingers and toes but he he is he's he is
a number of training approaches although
one sometimes wonders how much of what
he can do is attribute versus training
but for if we're cold exposure and also
for breath-holding I don't take us off
the rails but quit so quick note on
breath holding our mutual friend Josh
almost died from a shallow water
blackout in a pool you're doing breath
hole training you never do it in water
there's nearly no good reason yeah so
these guys have this metaphor of they're
basically coaching on your self-talk and
they're they say you should rub your
hands together and say bring it on when
you're anticipating doing some thing
that is going to be painful and it and
they use the metaphor of going into the
cold water at the at the beach and the
regular embracing of discomfort is a
skill that wait skin is also into and a
theme of like learning to he calls that
weights can cause on the other side of
pain but it's it's embrace getting used
to exposing yourself to paint on a
regular basis to the point where it's
you don't bounce off of it yeah Stutz
and Michaels observed that in their work
with producers agents screenwriters etc
in Hollywood that people were avoiding
doing the thing they needed to do it
they were bouncing off of it and so if
you can create a skill and a mechanism
to make yourself go into it and get in
that habit and they've got like six of
them any I think and so I do this with
my kids like will
literally rub our hands together and be
thinking okay bring it on 2x so I wonder
if Josh got this from you I mean it
wouldn't surprise me if you guys
independently arrived at this but with
with his son he would take cold showers
and he would always say it's so good and
he taught his son to say it's so good
with these short freezing cold showers
and I don't know son this probably
making this up four years old the time
and also taught his son to enjoy going
out and what other people would consider
bad weather right the rainstorms and so
on yeah so that's an example right of
just making yourself making the rain
object so let me think what Josh's
observing is that for most people they
are subject to the weather and they're
experiencing the weather is acting on
them right and a hack around that is to
say basically no I enjoy the rain I'm
gonna find what I enjoy in it and and
make it not the world happening to me
but but bringing the locus of control
internally don't I think he's doing
there oh yeah it's a parenting what I
mean any other boat that they've there
more books behind me then feel free to
that to mentioning them
I like finite and infinite games which
has been going around a lot his other
book breakfast at the victory this is
James cars James cars is really good he
had him to an event it had fun a retreat
we had a couple years ago and spent some
time with him and he's I think he's very
a very profound guy he was observing
that I asked him how he came up with the
concept of finite versus infinite games
and he said he was watching his kids
play and he noticed that there were some
games like card games or Baseball Center
where their whole motivation and intent
was to have the game end and get the
trophy and then he noticed there were
other games they were playing where
there are more fantasy games where their
goal was to recruit other people to play
in that game with them such as him as
their dad and the goal was to keep the
game going as long as possible I think
it's a super profound insight of the
different ways you can relate to games
in your life if you can see the game
you're playing
and that yeah I have some four examples
of infinite games which he doesn't give
in the book he mentioned as a religious
studies scholar he thinks Buddhism and
Judaism or two infinite games I guess in
religious studies neither of those has a
central authority or a central army so
it's unlike Catholicism they have
difficulty making sense of why it
persists over time and so the framework
of it's an infinite game those people
Buddhists and and Jews are recruiting to
various degrees people into their game
and wanting to just keep playing the
game for its own sake I thought that was
an interesting framing how does how do
you how does this the distinction of
finite and infinite games apply to
finance yeah if it does know it I think
it does I mean a finite player who's an
investment manager would be for instance
trying to hit a certain number of net
worth and then leave the game right and
that's okay but that makes it less
valuable of a partner from my
perspective and the incentives you can
get kind of weird
once they achieve that that worth if
they actually stick to it now the
reality is most people move the bar
there is a study everybody wants they
have all along the income spectrum
everybody wants to have two times where
they are right now but but I think there
are in general I seek out partners who
are playing ooh hiya experiences
infinite players who are are enjoying
the game for its own sake and are gonna
keep playing and and want to recruit
other people in and there's not that's
back to the distinction between being
commercial and transactional there's
something about the abundance mentality
behind someone who's commercial who's
trying to create more value than they
capture that's like leaving room for
other people
yeah in this way so yeah how do you how
do you how do you test for that or how
do you if that is it might be lower on
the hierarchy of needs in assessing
talent but if it if it is something that
you try to assess how do you assess it
the big the big one is time
if they're if they're somebody who's
thinking okay I found this thing that I
love to do I'm gonna do it for the next
20 years and I'm not gonna make
short-term accommodations to what's
going on in the market or with my
limited partners or with my team I
experience it around time horizon how do
you how do you ask around the question
especially after this podcast comes out
like okay Graham once a long time
horizon you see it just in a way they're
setting up their business the know it
there is there are indications of just
subtle mental framings on am i some
people start investment firms because
it's the time of their career where
they've kind of the their friends have
started investment firms they can no
longer stay at the container they're in
and they need to start yeah but it's not
an approach goal it's almost an avoidant
goal it's like okay this is the time
where I'm supposed to do this I'm gonna
do this versus a different set that are
like okay I found the thing I love I
found the ball I like to hit and I'm
gonna do it in this new form because and
that that implies to me a longer time
horizon and I it's a cliche but a love
of the game itself like they're not if
you took away David tippers money and
made him start at scratch right now I
think he'd enjoy it like he's just found
the thing he loves and who else has long
term chaco willing I think if Jacko's do
I would invest in something Jocko did I
think he has that exact in fact he
hasn't mantra right it is default
aggressive he has that mix of aggressive
in the integrity or aggressive in
humility and it you think he's coming
back from Iraqi to SEAL team great and
he's entering your world and he so this
is his podcast thing and then you know
the coaching thing and he from afar and
I don't know him I just really admire
the way he's doing his own thing he has
yeah that that mix of time horizon
having an idea execute
on it you guys should know each other oh
I'll introduce you guys you would get
along I want to I want to stay with this
for a little bit more in terms of like
sniffing around the direct question and
it seems like perhaps much like you're
tell me about tell me what about what
happened 2008 you can maybe also along
the lines of looking at how politicians
have have voted on things as opposed to
asking them what they will do it just
made me think that looking at time
horizon and sort of intrinsic versus
extrinsic motivations and so on you
could you could also assess kind of
along the same lines that Y Combinator
has at least historically by asking a
lot of questions around what people do
in their what they've built in their
spare time and things like that which
will not not be a direct answer to the
question but could act as indicators
that point to sort of a general pattern
of behavior and motivations yeah the way
I find Y Combinator's and Paul Graham's
the and say moment stuff hi signal for
my perspective so like they have this
question they ask themselves can you say
this person is an animal and not smile
like oh you know based on the references
based on your interactions with them
that's I think they're keying in on the
same quality of aggression or intensity
that I am Buffett uses passion and
common sense read alia uses
assertiveness and open-mindedness but I
think everybody's honing in on this
paradoxical tension that I was talking
about earlier so sorry what was tell me
the question again oh yeah no that I'm
not even sure I asked a question I think
was more of an of an observation and and
wondering if there are other ways to ask
around the the direct question of time
horizon which which I mean you already
gave a few examples of so I think it's
been answered so so let's let's pick up
on on one thing you also mentioned in
passing which which I'll refresh for
for people listening by reading a quote
and I'm gonna get this name wrong so
maybe you could this is a quote that you
introduced me to and it was it was one
of two candidates for answering question
what you would put on a gigantic
billboard anywhere and you could put
anything on it metaphorically speaking
write a message to get out to millions
or billions of people so could you read
this because it is it is stuck in my
mind and I've revisited it so many times
but I don't know the proper
pronunciation Club may Apia who's a
philosopher and why you actually I think
he used to be at Princeton has this
quote it's not how well you play the
game it's deciding what game you want to
play right and so you had mentioned the
game if you are aware that you're
playing the game so what is the what is
the relevance or importance of this this
quote for you I'll read it one more time
so it's not how well you play the game
it's deciding what game you want to play
oh I think that's a way of making your
game moving it from being subject to it
to object so an example would be I think
a huge number of people are obviously
playing the game of making money and
they're keeping score in terms of how
much money they make or how much fame
they accumulate or how much power they
accumulate and making that game object
to them and then just making sure that
you still want to play that game is I
think what his quote is about I ended up
writing an essay where I tried to
capture the various stages of mastery
and investment management that's on it's
a blog that's on my site and to me that
quote allows you to kind of zoom out and
say okay at different stages in my life
I'm gonna play different games what game
am I playing right now and can I see it
in fact that's what the coaches and the
coach I've used in the past helps you do
is say okay you're clearly optimizing
right now for this just make sure you
actually want that that's the game you
won so the ladder you're climbing is
leaning against the right wall let's
just make sure
it allows you to kind of it's like in a
video game it's the what do you call
that
cause I've you you know ads I've you
God's eye view of the game you're like
okay I'm down here in this corner of the
of the mountain range do I still want to
climb this mountain or is that a local
maximum and I should actually zoom out
in a head a completely different
direction
I think you've you've mentioned this to
me before and may even be in trouble
mentors but it makes me think of the
David Foster Wallace commencement speech
which has been turned into books and is
online in various forms but yes here it
is right here that is the this is water
yeah yeah right and in the story of what
is it the two the two young fish
together swim by the old the old fish
and the old fish doesn't passing like
how's the water boys is there something
like that or like what's water its
budget yeah exactly
I think that's what he's capturing so
beautifully in that in that commencement
speeches that we all have water there
are things that are water to us at every
stage of our life and the fun project is
to try to see it and you see it at each
stage it when I think of even the
development your development over the
course of the last several years on your
podcast like you're able to see you're
wrestling with different stuff you're
able to see your own quirks in a
different way than you were five years
ago and I think that's the process of
adult development that's what Keegan is
pointing to as these different stages I
I do the podcast in part because it
helps me to see the water mmm
I mean it's it forces me to try to ask
questions or make statements and
articulate things that would otherwise
just bounce around in my head
consciously or subconsciously a list of
the podcast is actually a tool for me to
try to discern which water I happen to
be swimming in yeah I which is which a
bit which makes it a lot of fun the the
the Greg McGowan is that recent I I said
it that way for a long time McEwan right
Greg McEwan's podcast with you recently
on essentialism when he tells that story
of how he felt a ton of pressure to go
on the work event
on the project with his consulting
partners rather than being at the
hospital with his wife right as she was
having a baby
that's a developmental in Kegan language
that's a developmental moment where he's
saying basically he's moving from
socialized to self authoring he's saying
basically no my partner's don't define
the scorecard here the scorecard is my
scorecard I decide what's a priority to
me and I'm never gonna I'm gonna remind
myself of this the rest of my life by
embarrassing myself by telling this
story over and over again so I don't do
it again
I feel like essentially it means
basically that's what he's capturing and
I think a lot of different moments in
your podcasts that's people are
wrestling with okay what what can they
see at that moment what did they use to
not be able to see and and that's the
it's kind of beautiful it's the
unfolding that we're all doing and you
think you've had an opportunity to
observe I don't know dozens hundreds
thousands of careers or at least look
examine probably thousands of different
careers how do you think about careers
or career advice I know that we've had
so much changes using the metaphor of
the river which might be a good place to
start and then I have some other some
other questions relate to that but maybe
we could begin begin with that yeah I
like I like the image of of a river with
two banks one side is chaos and the
other side is order it's something Dan
Siegel who's a neuroscientist came up
with to try to describe what mental
health is because he argued the the bank
of chaos is schizophrenia and the bank
of rigidity is OCD and that you could
basically put every mental illness on
one bank or another and that healthy
integration is swimming in the middle of
the river in between those two and I was
thinking about how careers are like that
that you start off along the rigidity
bank apprentice thing for somebody and
you're learning the jargon of that
industry and you're trying to figure out
how people define reality
but you're in somebody else's definition
in reality you're refining reality and
you're learning to be able to see
whereas the other bank the Kaos Bank is
more asserting reality that's where
people who are swimming right next to
that Bank are just making stuff up on
this massive like I think of Musk as
being right along that Bank and if some
if Tesla goes bankrupt that will mean he
lost his feed back with reality and kind
of stepped onto the Kaos Bank and he
pulls it off he was swimming right next
to it just Steve Jobs the same way
threading the needle
right so there's and as you know you see
it in poets you see it in writers people
who are right next to that bank or make
it are super original they're coming up
with new stuff we live in their
paradigms to some degree but you're
right on there if you if you lose the
feedback loop with the way the rest of
the world is experiencing reality all of
a sudden you can seem crazy and and and
the danger of swimming from a career
perspective of starting your own thing
you starting your own thing a lot of the
times is a project of asserting reality
and if you do it too early it can be
very disorienting and so you want to
just swim back and forth it's not to
discourage people from starting their
own things at a very young age but just
be aware that you're gonna that's the
project and you might want to come back
and refine reality for a little bit and
then go in just see it as fluid right it
makes you think of I'm not saying this
is it's kind of a direct mapping but
there's Pablo Picasso said learn the
rules like as an amateur so you can
break the rules as a professional
something along those lines the and you
mentioned you know this bank of chaos
and how those who sort of can swim right
alongside it can harness this paradigm
shifting originality but as you've also
pointed out that same originality can
have unintended consequences if they
flop onto the bank like Steve Jobs and
the magical thinking around
his illness yeah and it do the if one
wants to be top 1% in a given field just
arbitrarily to pull a number out of my
ass does that mean that they need to
swim really closely alongside one bank
or the other or is that a mistake in
thinking is it or be perceived as being
yeah top the a top performer do they do
they swim in the middle or do they
oscillate between the two
are there other different breeds just in
your experience yeah I don't I think to
be a top 1% depends it may be on the
field so let's say your world I think
within financial markets you need a
continual level of innovation to an
adaptability to stay ahead because the
games that were working five years ago
no longer work so for a while there were
a lot of event-driven strategies where
people were investing in mergers and
acquisitions and making a certain return
percentage around that that game has
mainly gone away and so I would say I
think of infinite players as playing
with the boundaries of the game so when
when Mike burry came up with the idea of
shorting subprime and the Mike burry
famously played by Christian Bale in the
DeJoria right like that that was a an
example of innovation and playing with
the boundary of the game at that time
because he wanted to express a view that
was short the housing market and he
found he had no he didn't want to short
stocks he wanted to get more leverage on
it he came up with that and then the
bank's offered that to everybody else
and everybody else ended up everybody
else who came into the trade ended up
following the trail that he had blazed
on that from my perspective there may be
other perspectives on that but that's my
perspective so you know is that is that
along I mean as Christian Bale portrayed
him he was wrestling with his sanity at
various points having that trade on his
various points the funder was down a lot
his partners were abandoning him
so I do think their machine the edge of
your field because people are gonna
catch up with you that is required I
don't know that you know I kind of think
of other examples outside of financial
markets of being top 1% of something
well yeah yeah it's it's less it's less
objective but if if we're looking at say
successful authors I think another
example that that I've that I've seen
you mentioned is persik yeah and wrote
the zen and the art of motorcycle
maintenance but certainly towards the
end got one might argue pretty pretty
loopy yeah it's hard to think of top 1%
in that in a yes its context but I think
original I mean you look at Rachel Cusk
and Carl of a knausgård I don't have
taste name but the those two authors
like I think they're doing original
things as novelists and are they're not
I don't think they're at risk of
flopping on to the bigger chaos but
they're doing original things yeah I
don't know how to think yeah one this is
this is more just just because I think
you'd enjoy it and I can I can link to
it for people are interested there's a
model of cognitive function or maybe but
what could ya suppose we put a cognitive
function and personality typing that has
been I'd say I guess the theory and a
model from Robin Carhartt Harris who's
scientist in the UK called the entropic
the entropic brain which I think you'd
enjoy so for another time yeah
what about about than just looking at my
notes here and I just have I have a
short I have two words based on
conversations we've had leading up to
this but I don't I don't have any
context here so time billionaires what
does that refer to
I was I was listening to a guy
introduced
speaker a while ago and he was saying
you know people don't really understand
the difference between billionaires and
millionaires he said you know a million
seconds is like 11 days a billion
seconds is 31 years that kind of sum all
the weak [ __ ] yes hell of a way to think
about it yeah make you say over time a
million seconds his 11 days a billion
seconds is slightly over 31 minutes and
I was thinking about Tyler Cohen has a
thing about cultural billion years
marginal revolution yeah yeah in one of
his books he talks about culture
billionaires and I like they I feel like
in our culture we're so obsessed as a
culture with money and we reify dollar
billionaires in a way that be nice to
reco op that term the way Tyler Cohen
did with cultural billionaires I was
thinking of time billionaires that when
I see sometimes 20 year olds you know
that the thought I had was they have
they they probably have two billion
seconds left and they did but they
aren't relating to themselves as time
billionaires and I was thinking about
how if if you could what would work
Murdoch is worth twenty billion dollars
he's 87 years old what would he pay for
if he could take the next five years of
someone's 20 year old healthy body mind
etcetera right and for that 20 year old
how would they price it yeah right
because I was thinking at first points
of my career I would I I might have sold
the next five years for something and
over time it's kind of my pricing has
gone vertical because the next five
years if I were to lose the key to this
question you can't sell the five at the
end of your life you gotta sell them
right now yeah like I don't know how I
price it because my kids are of a
certain age that they'll never be again
that it feels so but I don't know that I
live every day that way and so ice but I
aspire to so I was trying to capture you
know I heard Tim urban on your podcast
reading his stuff and I just find his
writing style and the topics he is
interested in just amazing it has this
concept of life calendar yeah and I I
bought his life calendar he sells it as
a poster and what he does is he puts a
week for he does a circle for each week
so he has 52 circles on the horizontal
and then 90 rows so that you can see a
90 year life in weeks
and what's startling about the picture
again to this question of ability how
long is a billion seconds is how short
it actually is and so what I did is I
went through and I put where I am right
now and I started filling in the circles
as I go and I put where my eldest
daughter goes to college
I put when my dad is going to be 90 and
I was actually thinking a good product
with 30 graphic designers out there
would be to partner with Tim and allow
you to create a huge poster and select a
photo for each week and then because
it's such a graphical representation of
your life in a way that's hard to Khmer
in in word sometimes but so I've just
been thinking a lot about time and how
you yeah how you live there's a quote I
like they you know we're all very
focused on the length of our life how do
you appreciate the width of it as you're
going along and somehow keeping that in
your consciousness
what do you can you elaborate on that
the width the width beating this present
moment we're sitting here having you
know if sort of like the depth of
attention yeah yeah the the breadth of
sensory inputs the being I mean it's
another way of saying trying to stay
more present versus being extremely
goal-directed of whatever whatever
object objective you have in your life
right now you know and how do you how do
you cultivate that in yourself so one
thing is I have that life calendar
literally sitting in my kitchen pause
pause quickly sometime also it's a team
urban has a blog wait but why I mean
calling it a blog is
funny because some of his pieces are
70,000 it's broken up into multiple
parts also just since you mention musk I
mean he was to you I believe the only
person asked by must directly was a fan
of the blog to come in and have full
access to Tesla if you if if the life
calendar is a fantastic place to start
as is a piece called the tail end if you
want a really acute sense of time
especially as it relates to how much
time you might have left with parents
you know that is a fantastic piece so
you have the calendar so that just so
that piece reading that piece made me
try to engineer having my parents in New
York much more frequently and ideally
did that oh they'll get it yeah so
literally reading that piece had that
big an impact I was like oh my gosh out
the percentages how if if you if your
parents don't live in the same place you
do you will see them by the time you
graduated from high school you've spent
like 95 percent of the time you'll ever
spend with little hours you will ever
spend with your parents yeah and that's
I didn't know I didn't know that about
about about you and your family after
reading that piece which was recommended
to me by Matt Mullenweg whose father
passed away very unexpectedly he
recommended that piece to me and that
led me to really block out and make a
priority a trip or a gathering with my
family every six months that piece yeah
yeah at the tail end for fun stuff so
your question is what do I do
so I mean all the standard stuff I
meditate I use 10% happier app yes Adam
Harris's app the Harris Harris brothers
even though they're not brothers so Dan
Harrison Sam Harris Dan Harris cause
that whole crew the Jews the Jewish
Buddhist I think well you know just this
is a quick side note that I remember
talking to Jack Kornfeld is an
incredible teacher I mean probably the
most and paths ik human I've ever met I
mean truly walks the walk and I asked
him at one point I said you've got
goldstein cornfield like the names like
Sharon Salzberg I'm like why are why are
it seems like the entire crew who
brought Buddhist mindfulness practices
to the u.s. hidden some of the let's say
I'm getting a time frame slightly off
probably but kind of Hades yeah like 70s
80s they're all Jewish and he goes that
is a good question this is just us
having a private conversation but he
said yeah it sounds like a law firm and
we went on if we want to get get to put
the Juba yes so Dan Harris Sam Harris
both of those apps yeah I use both those
apps
I try to be nostalgic for spending time
with my kids in the present moment so
like my youngest right now I think I can
probably carry on my shoulders probably
a total of five more times just getting
too heavy yeah and I knew because I have
an older kid that there's that's a
distinct phase mmm-hmm
but I don't I don't be on those keeping
track yeah
of how much time those are all I mean
that those are good anchor points
they're good should Rubin line about how
the days are long but the years are
short I think about that a lot there's
an there's one that's that boy I wish I
could get the attribution right it was
actually it was it was in charm of
mentors it was a it was an answer to one
of my questions isn't one of the other
profiles but for a technologist I know
that much
and it was a it was in answer to the
question what do you do when you feel
overwhelmed or unfocused and the and
this was a question that he asked
himself which was in effect and how much
would I pay at sort of age 8090 looking
back in my life
how much would I pay to relive this
moment right now and I asked that a lot
whether it's just it's like sitting on
the grass watching my dog play with a
stick or any number of times that's a
question that I ask myself a lot like 40
years from now how much would I pay I
think about I mean it's it's the same
Harris on his app has a great
three-minute gratitude
and he says imagine you died yesterday
evening how much how much you would have
what you would give me back in this
moment of having a shitty dinner with
your kids and wife we're all like in a
bad mood and you're all in this very
contracted state I think that's such a
it borders on the cliche but it there's
something in just daily reminders of
that I think a lot about the buyer and
Katie thing of the past and the future
are simulations in your head and the
only thing that's actually real is this
current now a moment that we're in soon
we talked about a little bit earlier
well we'll do a couple more questions
and and then we can we can wrap for this
round one on this podcast we talked
about your one option for the Billboard
and which was the the kwame quote are
there any other quotes statements
questions words anything that you might
put on a billboard
besides that yeah another candidate
would be this quote we are not human
beings having a spiritual experience we
are spiritual beings having a human
experience welcome to the party and
that's a mash-up of Pierre shoda the is
a French Jesuit priest and philosopher
and then there's a meditation on the 10%
happier app called welcome to the party
by Jeff Warren where you're saying to
every negative feeling everything that
comes up welcome to the party and he
says imagine you're an affable host like
that and he's this great moment earlier
this week where my son seven year old is
still afraid of the dark in his room and
he was running back to get his clothes
and he yelled out welcome to the party
fear in the dark which is so made me so
proud because he's able to write he's
that fears object to him like he can
feel his feelings right
but anyway I like that quote because
every time I read it it shifts that oh
this is our key this is what it's like
right now this is a human experience and
and somehow this is our moment to have
it yeah yeah like that no I I haven't I
really like it I've been reading a lot
of writing from Jesuits recently for
some reason I don't and I'm not sure if
it's a Jesuit thing or if it's just just
coincidence that I happen to be picking
these up I really don't know the first
thing about the Jesuit Order but the the
b-line
welcome to the party's so helpful
because I've certainly read a thousand
times in different forms making your
emotions an object or not identifying
for instance with I am angry but
phrasing in some fairly unnatural way
like I am currently experiencing anger
okay fine but this is much more
memorable and it's being the affable
host yeah your whole range of emotions
including like when like grumpy Kent
anchors uncle shows up and you're like
hey bud
welcome to the party alright look at you
Hatter are today absolutely you know
come over have some punch welcome to the
party I love it I love it
any others I also love this quote from
Mark Twain right before he died he was
looking back at his life and he said
something like there isn't time so brief
his life for bickerings apologies
heart-burnings callings to account
there's only time for loving and but an
instant so to speak for that and i like
that because i think the perspective of
somebody who's really old and dying is
so so i find somehow extra-high signal
because you they're trying to draw your
attention to something while you're
still at an earlier place of your life
and somehow I found myself thinking
about that
goula that all this stuff that feels so
high drama once you're you know when
you're 90 looking at it you're gonna be
able
you're just gonna say it was all noise
in there yeah yeah or right it's it's
it's all noise end or like the day after
you die if you're looking down and
you're like God what I would give to
have that shitty meal that I thought was
the last place I would want to be what I
would give to have that again yeah
Graham if I always loved spending time
together and thank you for making the
time thank you for having me there was
fun yeah this is a lot of fun I've ton
of notes I've taken from myself already
and books I want to pick up welcome to
the party that I want to listen to
people can find you in number different
places I'll just repeat them you know
Graham Duncan dot blog where they can
find that essay that you mentioned
earlier and East Rock Capcom at Graham
Duncan NYC on Twitter if they want to
wave say hello on the Internet
is is there anything else you'd like to
mention things you'd like people to
check out requests you would have the
audience suggestions anything at all
that you'd like to say before we before
we wrap up well I'll just note I helped
produce this conference called the Sun
conference we do it in partnership with
CNBC and we raise money for pediatric
cancer and we do that by bringing 15
headphone managers and venture
capitalists together at Lincoln Center
they each bring an actual investment
idea and we're doing it this year May
6th in Lincoln Center so anybody
listening if you can afford it to donate
come if you can't afford to donate DM me
on Twitter and I'll come up with some of
our free tickets but it's a great it's a
great gift exchange we have we're
basically the Hedgehog managers bring
their ideas people pay money to come
hear them and then we give that money to
the leading pediatric cancer researchers
so that would be one that's the the Sohn
Conference foundation Soh and which
which I've attended before and found
endlessly fascinating
endlessly fascinating took but yeah yeah
fun day yeah it's it's a really mind
stretching experience anything else
you'd like to like to say uh-huh no I
think that's it I mean no all right full
stop
Graham until next time and we feel we
have a lot to otherwise catch up on but
thank you again yeah thanks for being so
generous with your time and your
caffeinated beverages and to everybody
listening I will have links to
everything in the show notes
the books the essays the various figures
people thinkers we mentioned which you
can find as always at tim dot blog
forward slash podcast and just search
Graham or Duncan and everything will pop
right up and until next time pay
attention to the present that's all you
got all right thanks guys bye hey guys
this is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun for the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour work week
calm that's 4-hour work week
komm all spelled out and just drop in
with your email and you'll get the very
next one and if you sign up I hope you
enjoyed this episode of the Tim Ferriss
show is brought to you by 99designs
99designs is the global creative
platform that makes easy for creators
and clients to work together from logos
to apps and packaging to book covers
just about anything can be found on
99designs which is a go to creative
resource for any budget that i've used
for many many years now 99 design now
offers guess what custom video which is
very exciting they will match you at the
right video professional to help you
explain your product spotlight a service
and bring your brand to life and like I
mentioned I've used 99 designs for all
sorts of things I've used them book
covers some of the mock-ups for the
4-hour body for example which went on to
become a number one York Times best
seller illustrations beautiful
illustrations cover and inside
illustrations for the multi-volume the
Tao of Seneca which you can find online
for free that is a collection of my
favorite letters that I've read hundreds
of times by Seneca and other graphic
design projects most recently I used 99
designs to update the illustrations and
layout of my 5 morning rituals ebook
which is something that I offer as an
incentive on my website for people to
sign up for my free newsletter the
illustrations turned out fantastic and I
loved working with a designer who we
selected for the project you can check
out a bunch of these projects you can
see real-life examples of what I've done
and the story behind them at 99 designs
calm or slash Tim the number 99 designs
compote slash Tim 9 and designs will
match you with the right professional
for your project from the curated
community of talented creatives and stay
with you every step of the way so you
love the outcome let's check it out
head to 99designs dot-com forward slash
Tim to learn more and get started on
your project today this episode is
brought to you by LinkedIn marketing
solutions the go-to tool for BP
marketers and advertisers who want to
drive brand awareness generate leads or
build long-term relationships that
result in real business impact could be
all of the above I've had Reid Hoffman
co-founder of LinkedIn on this podcast
the number of
often called the Oracle of Silicon
Valley for many different reasons and he
among other people and friends of mine
have made me more and more interested in
LinkedIn as a platform as an ecosystem
in the last few years and it's it's very
nuanced it's very subtle but can be used
in some very powerful ways with a
community of more than five hundred and
seventy five million professionals
LinkedIn is gigantic but it can be hyper
specific you have access to a very
diverse group of people all searching
for things they need to grow
professionally that is explicitly the
purpose of LinkedIn and four out of five
users on LinkedIn are decision-makers at
their companies so you can build
relationships that really matter that
can drive your business objectives
forward that can also have a high LTV
lifetime value LinkedIn has the
marketing tools to help you target your
customers with precision right down to
among other things their job title
company name industry etc this is
important because better targeting
equals a message that your customers
actually care about and it also means
your advertising is more effective and
cost effective so why spray-and-pray
with your marketing dollars when you can
be surgical it just makes sense to
redeem a free $100 LinkedIn ad credit
and launch your first campaign go to
linkedin.com forward slash TFS that
stands for Tim Ferriss show so that is
linkedin.com forward slash TFS check it
out that's where you can go to get your
free $100 ad credits LinkedIn com
forward slash TFS terms and conditions
apply
[Music]
[Applause]